hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today we're going to
be continuing our series on a gear
casbah verse deep blue or in game number
six and the 1996 matchup between the
grandmaster and the IBM supercomputer if
you've been following the series up
until this point garry kasparov going
into game number six is up three to two
and he's going to be playing the white
pieces during this game so with one game
left all Garry Kasparov really has to do
is not lose if he ties he'll end up
winning three and a half points to two
and a half points so as long as he can
win or tie he's going to be crowned the
champion so most players in this
situation would play fairly aggressive
since they are white but in the back of
their mind think okay I can pretty much
play for a draw which is much easier
than trying to play for a win the good
thing for the chess world is that Garry
Kasparov said ah forget this idea I'm
gonna go for blood and I'm gonna try to
win this thing for two - and that's
exactly what he does so we're going to
go ahead and get into it it's a
fantastic game a great way to wrap up
the 1996 series between Garry Kasparov
and deep blue again what's going to be
played by Garry Kasparov and black is
going to be played by the IBM
supercomputer deep blue white starts
with Knight to f3 simple development
move this is the ready open and really
gives white a lot of flexibility into
how he wants to transition later into a
specific opening Black's going to
respond with pawn to d5 white plays pawn
to d4 and Black's gonna play pawn to c6
getting into one of these slob defenses
White's now going to play pawn to c4
this is the Queen's Gambit line Black
has the option of either taking here on
c4 taking the game it or he can decline
it now black does decide to decline it
with pawn to e6 and this is the semi
Slav line now a lot of people when
they're watching these videos actually
want to go watch the defense on the semi
Slav to kind of figure out what that's
about so feel free to do that if you
want to but this is the semi Slav line
the difference is a Slav line typically
you'll bring out the LightSquared Bishop
before you kind of solidify that pawn
chain but the semi Slav says okay I'm
going to bring my pawn here to e6 now
it's very very important as you can tell
this LightSquared Bishop is blocked in
really really has to have a lot of
counterplay later on or he's really
going to be squeezed as you can see he's
building a pretty solid defense but his
pieces aren't very active he's really
starting to block some of his pieces in
so if he doesn't really have a strong
counter-attack he's pretty much going to
be squeezed he's not going to have a lot
of room to move with all of his pieces
that definitely holds true anytime you
see the semi slob it's also going to
hold true in this game as well so just
keep that in mind and the back your head
is you're kind of watching this video as
far as Garrigus bob knows that he's now
playing the semi Slav so he now has a
very very specific way he's going to be
playing against black now White's going
to play Knight to d2 a lot of times you
will just see Knight to c3 this is a
okay move if you see this and you're
playing this as well Knight to c3 is
definitely okay a lot of times these
grandmasters will do a lot of you know
studying on different variations in
lines that they think are you know
sometimes just as good but people
haven't really studied a lot so
sometimes they'll try them out here and
there but make no mistake about it he's
definitely done his research and he
knows that Knight to d2 here is it very
playable move now keep in mind that
Garrick spot is blocking off this Bishop
here on c1 typically if you're going to
play this you're going to be bringing
your bishop somewhere else since he has
blocked it off from coming along this
long diagonal here so look for Jericho's
bhakta to be bringing his bishop to
either B 2 or a 3 kind of these long
diagonals here blacks now I'm going to
respond with Knight to f6 simple
development move trying to control the
center of the board needs definitely get
some of those minor pieces involved into
the game
White's going to play pawn to e3
solidifying his pawn chain also getting
ready to bring his light square bishop
involved into the game so you can go and
castle on the King side now Black's
gonna play pawn to c5 trying again
trying to get some of that
counter-attack in this game wants to
make sure that all his pieces are not
just in the back with no room to breathe
it all so why it's now going to play
pawn to b3 really both sides aren't
capturing anything they're just really
trying to solidify the center of the
board really trying to just
develop all their pieces and then attack
later on so as we've already talked
about this Bishop now can come to be too
if he wants to you can come to a three
depending on where black moves but this
move right here needed to come anyway
because again this dark square Bishop
needed to get out here so this is a
natural move for Gege spob to bring his
bit his pawn to b3 so definitely okay
with that
now the Knights going to come to c6
again simple vellum move controlling the
center of the board right here if this
pawn on you know c5 doesn't come here a
lot of times you'll see the knight come
to d7 and then try to start a
counter-attack on either side but in
this case since the pawn has already
come to c5 then the Knights going to go
ahead and come right behind it on c6
who's starting to put a lot of pressure
on this pawn on d4 now White's going to
respond with Bishop to b2 again
solidifying again early game you always
want to have your pawns controlling the
sin of the board and your minor pieces
are going to be supporting those pawns
of the center of the board now later on
into the game you're going to have your
minor pieces doing a lot of the
attacking with your major pieces your
rooks in your queen supporting those
pieces and then late-game if you have
those major pieces they're really going
to be doing a lot of the the action but
that's kind of what you're seeing here
the pawns controlling the sin of the
board and the minor pieces simply
supporting those in the center of the
board from here black is going to take
on d4 and why it's going to recapture
with this pawn on d4 again there's no
reason for white to capture with these
minor pieces early on into the game they
really want to be supporting those pawns
which are controlling the center of the
board so from here black is going to
play Bishop to e7 definitely wants to
make sure that he gets his dark squared
Bishop out so we can castle on the King
side and black is going to bring or
excuse me why it's going to bring his
rook over to c1 now again it's going to
be fine if you know white brings his
Bishop over to let's say d3 he's going
to need to eventually get his light
squared Bishop involved into the game so
either way is fine
white just wants to go ahead and get
ready for in case this is recapture that
he has this on a semi-open file now
black is going to castle on the King
side
and then why it's going to play Bishop
to d3 again getting ready to castle on
the kingside now blacks going to play
Bishop to d7 again he still has it kind
of blocked here for me six so he can't
get it too far but definitely wants to
make sure that he has all of his minor
pieces developed somewhat so we can
start again to counter-attack White's
now going to castle on the King side and
then Black's going to play Knight to h5
he really wants to play in Knight to f4
and then take this Bishop on d3 White's
pieces are much more active than black
and as you'll see kind of later on to
the game white really has a strong
attack he's trying to open up the game
and point both of his bishops against
the black King right here dual bishops
especially when you get the game open
are very very powerful together so black
now knows that he needs to actually
start taking some initiative and start
to trade off for some of these pieces
that later on could cause a huge pain
point for black why it's now going to
respond with rook to e1 again you always
want to put your rooks on semi-open
files right here this is a great spot
this rook now can roam on the first rank
and it can also roam on this ePHI right
here so a great spot for this rook black
is going to respond with his knight
coming to f4 is kind of we talked about
and then why it's just going to kick his
his bishop back to b1 still trying to
control this long diagonal here
definitely MIT wants to make sure he
does not tray that off really just
doesn't do anything for him he has the
more active pieces he has the kind of
better setup right now so right now he
wants to make sure that he has all those
aggressive pieces on the board doesn't
want to trade those off from here the
bishop is going to come to d6 not I
think really in this case you could
easily bring you know the rook over to
c8 if you're kind of looking at this and
trying to figure out you know why do
people play what they do when where
should I be looking you know simple
things to think about you know bringing
this rook over to c8 this is a semi-open
file
you know White has a semi-open file here
on the
so bringing the rook over to c8 very
very powerful move you know instead
black decides to go ahead and centralize
his Bishop a little bit more with Bishop
to d6 and then why it's going to play
pawn to g3 since this Bishop has come
back he knows the sides ok this Knights
kind of getting in my way so I'm going
to go ahead and kick him back so the
Knights now going to come back to g6 and
why it's going to play Knight to e5 this
Knight really isn't doing as much as you
know he needs as far as his attack again
he's really looking to expand on the
Queen side and then really open up the
King side here for his bishops to really
get involved into the game so he's going
to go ahead and try to sacrifice one of
his knights try to open up the game take
away some of the pieces but leave a lot
of space for his pieces to kind of roam
around the game black responds with rook
to c8 count as what we talked about
before I think you should have done it
first I guess if he is the computer but
again I think the supercomputer probably
could have done that first
from here the Knights going to take here
on d7 exchanging the knight for the
bishop again that's exactly what garrix
Roth wants to do he wants to have the
dual bishop pair and wants to take the
bishops off the board for his opponent
now the Queen's going to recapture hair
on d7 so black has now finished his
development he has all of his pieces
involved into the game and he also has
connected his rooks White's now going to
play Knight to f3 again opening the
board up a little bit more he now has a
little bit more room for his Queen to
roam around and now blacks going to play
Bishop to b4 coming down to attack it's
really not going to do too much the
rooks just going to come up here to e3
and then black is going to play rook
over to d8 again this rook move it's
kind of a waiting move there's not a lot
of space for black to go right now so
he's kind of just waiting right now more
than likely trying to just find some
mistake from white you know really
there's no easy way
there's not even a hard way right now
for black to win this game so
unfortunately for him the best
he could probably do his tie but garry
kasparov has other plans from here why
it's going to play pawn to h4 again he's
gonna eventually attack on the Queen
side but he wants to start to put
pressure on the King side and he
realizes it with this setup did black
he's pretty much just choking himself
and he really doesn't have a lot of room
there's really no good way for him to
come over to the King side and actually
counter-attack so he's going to start
pushing forward he already has all of
his pieces lined up against this you
know black King over here so he says I'm
going to go ahead and start pushing my
pawns up your face as well black is now
going to bring his knight back to e7
again being pretty passive with his
pieces and now white really starts to
push his pieces forward and not only
does he push his pieces for but as
you'll see you know he starts to kick
back the bishop and he's going to push
forward with his pawn here again moving
these back moving his pawns forward and
moving them with tempo he's now going to
bring his pawn up to c5 but he's choking
black more and more blacks getting fewer
and fewer squares that he can move his
pieces to and that he's also opening the
board up for his pieces again his his
bishops are just getting more and more
room to move around
his queen is going to become a lot more
active as you can see black is just kind
of all on this 3x3 square right here the
Queen really can't move anywhere the
rooks back here are completely blocked
off and so blacks just kind of in this
waiting game where white has complete
control over the board which a lot of
times is what you see when you play the
semi slob if you don't have a very very
strong counter attack from here blacks
going to bring his rook over to e8 again
kind of a waiting move no real
initiative that he can do just kind of
waiting for white so white plays Queen
to d3 centralizing a little bit more
putting a lot of pressure obviously
threatening to take here on h7
supercomputers now going to play pawn to
g6 definitely wants to make sure that he
stops this and now the rook is going to
come back to e2 and the Knights going to
come over here to f5 garrix Bob wants to
make sure that he's being very active
he's not responding any things
he wants to go ahead and bring this rook
back to e2 even before this night comes
to f5 and then has to respond to that so
gear exposure says you know I'm going to
be in complete control
I'm not even going to move in response
to you I'm going to do it before you
even get there so whites now going to
bring his bishop to c3 and black is
going to play pawn to h5 trying to
counter-attack on the Kings side wants
to make sure that white doesn't push up
any further so really trying to give
himself a little bit more room to
breathe but a little bit too late in
this situation White's going to continue
to push forward on the Queen side it
plays pawn to b5 the Knights going to
come back to e7 it's pretty passive move
you know Knight to a5 is a lot more
aggressive obviously a knight on the the
rim is dim but in this case bringing the
knight back to e7 is not doing a whole
lot at least in this case you know he
can always bring it to c4 he does have
this nice little outpost form from this
pawn on d5 so he does have a lot of
options here if the bishop takes then
black can respond and take with his
bishop here trading off one of these
dark square bishop that garrix Bob
really wants to hold on to so you know
a5 would have you know potentially
giving him some counter play right here
but instead he decides to play a little
bit more passive and let Gary Kasparov
continue to push forward and just
completely smother him with his pieces
and just really give block nowhere to
move so again Knight to e7 here and then
the bishop comes over to d2 blacks
Cannery Pont respond with King to g7
trying to get a little bit of room again
to breathe and the pawns not going to
come to a4 he's just going to start to
push forward with his pawns really not
going to be a whole lot that he can do
now from here black has different
options
I think the option you chose is probably
wrong he chose rook over to a 8pi would
have been a little bit more aggressive
if he played you know pawn to a6 trying
to get some counter play here if he can
kind of open this board up trade off
some of these pawns he can start to
swing his rooks over here and try to get
some counter play on the Queen side
but instead he just kind of moves his
rook along the eighth-ranked which
doesn't do a whole lot of good and
Garrigus barb just continues to push
forward he plays pawn to a5 and now it's
a little bit too late
the pawns now going to come to a6 and
now this pawns are just going to push
forward to b6 again this is just
strangling this bishop right here on c7
really doesn't have anywhere to go
so he comes back to b8 and now this rook
here on a 8 is kind of tracked so as we
talked about before probably the best
move to bring the rook over to a8 and
now we look at it and it's just kind of
trapped the Starks where bishops can
have a hard time actually coming out
into the game you can't come to c7 you
know D 6 e 5 or F 4 is going to be
captured so it's going to be a hard time
for black to get any sort of counter
play with this rook on it on a 8 a lot
of times if you've seen any of the other
games that I've analyzed you'll say you
know such-and-such player gave up
material and then they pretty much had
more active pieces than their opponent
and it's all about the amount of pieces
you have in the fights now how many
pieces you have it's about how many
pieces you have in the fight in this
case garry kasparov has the same amount
of pieces on the board he also has way
more guys in the fight Ike in black is
really not doing a lot just kind of
waiting for gierek's prof to run over
him so garry kasparov obliges with that
request White's now going to come bring
his bishop to C to just kind of setting
everything up he can pretty much take
his time he knows that black really
doesn't have a lot of counter play so he
can slowly and methodically set up his
pieces exactly how he wants to now the
Knights going to come back to c6 and
then the bishop is going to come over
here to a for pinning this knight down
on c6 to the Queen right here on d7 the
rooks are going to come over here to e7
and the bishops now going to come to c3
now black does have some counter play
and he actually plays Knight to e5 again
this is you know opening up the door for
the bishop to take on d7 but it's also
allowing him to cap
true this Queen here on d3 that's
actually going to be a mistake if white
captures here on d7 the night will come
down here to d3 and take if it would be
a terrible move if you know let's say
white decided to you know move his
Bishop out of the way then he would lose
his rook here on c1 if he decided to you
know bring his pawn up to let's say c6
to hold on to this Bishop then he's
going to lose his rook here on c1 if he
instead decides you know bringing his
rook over to d1 he again is going to
lose his bishop here on d7 he's really
not going to have as many active pieces
as he'd really like to so this is not
the option that he chooses instead he's
he decides to go ahead and just take
with his pawn right here on e5 and then
after the bishop takes he's now going to
bring his knight over here to d4 and
then they're going to exchange their
Knights and the Queen's going to come to
d4 so much better position for for white
right now black no longer has any pieces
that he has any sort of counter play so
he decides to go ahead and bring his
queen back to d7 white responds with
Bishop to d2 black responds bringing his
rook back to e8 and now the bishop comes
over here to g5 great square it's an
outpost from this pawn here on h5 it's
going to be really hard for him to kick
this off again this Bishop here MBA it's
not going anywhere and really you know
this pawn really can't come forward
because the pawn here on e5 which white
recently put there is kind of blocking
this so this is going to be a great
square really limiting you know the few
pieces or squares that black has pretty
much limiting all those right here so
blacks going to bring his rook over to
c8 pretty much just moving all his
pieces to one side of the board not
really doing a whole lot trying to get
some sort of counter play on this semi
open file on the C file but just too
little too late the bishop is now going
to come to f6 a little more central
square for this Bishop again he had an
outpost here on g5 he also has an
outpost here
six the king is going to come over here
to age seven and now the ponds gonna
push forward now Black has two options
he can either take it you know with his
pawn you can also take it with his rook
he's not really going to think of it as
Queen because then he'll lose that but
you know if he takes it with his rook
then you know white can swing over here
after the exchange why it's gonna be
doing much better it's going to be
really hard for black to do anything so
it doesn't matter what black does he
doesn't have a whole lot of great
options he decides to go ahead and take
the reason white gives up this material
is that he knows that later on he can
push forward with this pawn to b7 and
that's definitely going to be winning so
after black takes right here on c6 then
white brings his queen to c5 kind of
solidifying this making sure that this
pawn doesn't push forward anymore
again he wants to take away all the
squares the black and move and
completely choke him to death now the
black Kings going to come over here to
h6 White's not really worried about that
he's going to swing his rook over here
to be two again he wants to push forward
with his pawn to b7 he's going to be
capturing one of these rooks on a eight
or c8 so just too much would like to
deal with he brings his Queen over to b7
and now the route comes here to b4 if he
wants to he can always bring swing his
rook over here to b1 just too much for
black to handle and he from here just
decides to resign the next move from
white if it continued he could always
bring his Queen to e7 and after the
Queens trade off again then this pawn
could come to b7 it's just going to be
too hard for him to handle especially if
the other rook comes over here to to b1
why it's going to be able to promote his
pawn or is going to be able to take one
of these pieces blacks just really not
going to have any response so again
fantastic win for garrix probably ninety
six ends up winning in defeating deep
blue the IBM supercomputer 42 pretty
much you know stakes claim that at this
time obviously things have changed but
at this time in 1996 humans are still
better at chess than computers so
hopefully you guys enjoyed this video
we'll be starting a new series
surely on the 1997 rematch between Garak
suave and the blue but hope you guys
enjoyed it and I'll see you guys in the
next video thanks for watching